July 2013 the European Space Agency
cryosat-2 satellite uses radar
technology to build 3d maps of
Antarctica it discovers something no one
was expecting to see a giant hole in the
ice the hole appears east of the Ross
Ice Shelf it captures the attention of
glaciologist kelly brunt the depression
in the ice she's about three times the
size of the island of Manhattan so it's
a very big hole it's about 150 to 200
feet deep so we want to know what is
going on here scientists attempt to find
a natural explanation for the disturbing
phenomenon
they first consider that warm ocean
currents could have created the hole by
melting the ice from below but there's a
problem with this theory the giant hole
is miles from the ocean scientists now
believe there's something ancient
lurking beneath the ice that created the
hole in the geological past Antarctica
actually had a different climate perhaps
1015 million years ago there was an
opportunity for running water to it to
have existed on the surface that water
has got trapped as Lakes a couple of
miles sometimes down beneath the ice
sheets those lakes have been trapped
there for millions of years
these ancient subterranean bodies of
water are known as ghost lakes we call
these Lakes ghost lakes because very
invisible to us until the something
happens and they reveal themselves
aerial scans using
ice-penetrating radar reveal an anomaly
almost a mile and a half beneath the
surface directly beneath the hole it
looks exactly like a ghost lake
the waters entirely at the base of the
ice sheets
despite being thousands of feet beneath
the ice the water in the lakes remains
liquid and it can move from one ghost
lake to another these leaks spread
throughout the continent and they're
interconnected as one lake drains it
could fill another lake downstream and
as water in that system in a lake moves
from one place to another the ice sheet
loses that pressure that's holding it up
and it tends to drop it appears that the
movement of the underground water caused
a slump in the surface ice creating the
giant hole
you